the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last time we started talking about
complexity and I want to quickly remind
you of what we're doing because we're
going to talk some more about that today
and when I say complexity it was the
question of can we estimate the amount
of resources typically time that we're
going to need to get an algorithm to
solve a problem of a particular size and
we talked about that both in terms of
estimating how much time is it going to
take and using it to go the other
direction and think about how design
choices in an algorithm have
implications for the cost it's going to
be associated with that so we introduced
the idea of what we call Big O notation
orders of growth a way of measuring
complexity and we started talking about
different classes of algorithms so today
I'm going to quickly recap those basic
ideas and what we're going to do is
we're going to see examples of standard
classes of algorithms with the idea that
you're going to want to begin to
recognize when an algorithm is in that
class so very quick recap I've already
said part of this we want to have a
mechanism a method for being able to
estimate or reason about how much time
do we think an algorithm is going to
take to solve a problem of a particular
size and especially as we increase the
size of the input to the algorithm what
does that do in terms of the increase in
the amount of time that we need some
ways we don't care about exact versions
in a second we're going to see the
definition of this but what we care
about is that notion of how does it grow
as we increase the problem size and what
we're going to focus in going if you
like in the forward direction as I said
a lot of the interest is actually
thinking about what you might think of
as the backwards or reverse direction
how does a choice in algorithm design
impact efficiency of the algorithm and
really what we want you to do is to
begin to recognize standard patterns
that if you make a particular choice
this fits in a class of algorithms
you've seen before and I know in essence
how much time what the cost is going to
be as I do that all right so just to
recap as I said
on the top we talked about orders of
growth the idea is we want to be able to
evaluate programs efficiency when the
input is very big we talked about timing
things just with a timer we suggested
that unfortunately conflates the
algorithm with the implementation with
the particular machine we want to get
rid of those latter two and just focus
on the algorithm so we're going to talk
about counting operations but in a very
general sense so we're going to express
what we call the growth of the program's
runtime as the input size grows very
large and because we're only interested
not an exact number but in if you like
the growth of that we're going to focus
on putting an upper bound on the growth
an expression that grows at least as
fast as what the cost of the algorithm
is now you could just cheat and pick a
really big upper bound that doesn't help
us very much so in general we're going
to try and use as tight an upper bound
as we can what's the class of algorithm
it falls in but as we've seen before we
care about the order of growth not being
exact so something grows as two to the N
+ 5 n I don't care about the 5 n because
when n gets big that 2 to the N is the
really big factor and therefore we're
going to look at the largest factors
when we think about that seen some
examples we're going to do a bunch more
examples today to fill those in and one
of the things that we want to now do is
say with that idea in mind there are
classes of complexity of algorithms so
some sense the best ones are way up here
o of one order one constant it says cost
doesn't change as I change the size of
the input it's great it's always going
to be the same cost order log n says the
cost grows logarithmically with the size
of the input it's a slow growth I'm
going to remind you that in a second we
saw lots of examples of linear running
time we're going to see a few more today
what we call log linear polynomial and
exponential and the thing I want to
remind you is that ideally oops sorry
we'd like our algorithms to be as close
to the top of this categorization as we
can this is actually described in
increasing
of complexity something that takes the
same amount of time no matter how big
the input is unless that amount of time
is a couple of centuries seems like a
really good algorithm to have something
that grows linearly is not bad something
that grows as we've seen down here
exponentially tends to say this is going
to be painful and in fact you can see
that graphically just remind you here
something this constant says if I draw
out the amount of time it takes as a
function of the size of the input
it doesn't change logarithmic glows
grass or it grows very slowly linear
will grow obviously in a linear way
and I actually misspoke last time I know
it's rare for a professor to ever admit
they misspeak but I did because I said
linear is if you double the size of the
input it's going to double the amount of
time it takes actually that's an
incorrect statement really what I should
have said was the increment if I go from
say ten to a hundred the increase in
time is going to be the same as the
increment if I go from a hundred to a
thousand might be more than double
depending on what the constant is but
that growth is linear if you want to
think of it take the derivative of time
with respect to input size it's just
going to be a constant it's not going to
change within and of course when we get
down to hear things like exponentially
grows really fast and just as a last
recap gain I want to be towards the top
of that there was my little chart just
showing you things that grow constant
log linear log linear quadratic and
exponential if I go from n of ten to a
hundred to a thousand to a million you
see why I want to be at the top of that
chart something up here that grows
logarithmically the amount of time grows
very slowly as I increase the input down
here well like it says good luck it's
going to grow up really quickly as I'm
as I move up in that scale I want to be
at the top of this chart if I can okay
with that in mind what I'm going to do
today is show you examples filling in
most of this chart we've already seen
some examples we've seen examples of
linear we've seen examples of quadratic
I'm going to streamlined you that's what
I want to do is show you how you can
begin to recognize that
of an algorithm in terms of where it
lies so algorithms that are constant
complexity the kind of boring they tend
to be pretty simple because this says
this code is going to run in the brief
basically the same amount of time
independent of the size of the input now
notice the bottom thing here it doesn't
say you can't you there try again it
doesn't say you couldn't have a loop or
a recursive call you could it's just
that that loop cannot depend on the size
the input so there aren't many
interesting algorithms here we're going
to see pieces of code that fit into this
when we do our analysis but something
that's constantly complexity says
independent of the size of the input
right a little more interesting not a
little a lot more interesting or
algorithms that are logarithmic in their
complexity since they're going to grow
with the logarithm of the size of the
input you saw an example much earlier in
the term when Anna showed you bisection
search was searching for a number with a
particular property I want to show you
another example both the let you
recognize the form of the algorithm but
especially to show you how we can reason
about the growth and that's another
trick called binary search or a game
it's a version of bisection search
suppose I give you a list list of
numbers integers and I want to know if a
particular element is in that list we
saw last time you could just walk down
the list just iterate through the entire
list looking to see if it's there in the
worst case which is what we worried
about it's going to be linear you only
have to look at every element to the lid
in the list till you get to the end so
complexity was linear in that case and
then we said suppose we know that the
list is sorted it's ordered from
smallest to largest and we saw simple
algorithm says again walk down the list
checking to see if it's there but when
you get to an element that's bigger than
the thing you're looking at you can just
stop it's no reason to look at the rest
of the list they've all got to be bigger
than the thing you're searching for
practically in the average case that's
going to be faster than just looking at
an unsorted list but the complexity is
still linear because in the worst case
I've got to go all the way through the
list before I do some thing is
there okay so even sequential search and
an ordered list is still linear can we
do better and the answer is short so
here's how we do better I'm going to
take that list I'm going to assume it's
sorted and I'm going to pick an index
that divides the list in half just pick
the midpoint in the list and I'm going
to check that value when I ask is the
element in the list at that point the
thing I'm looking for if it is great I'm
done
if I'm not that lucky I'm then going to
ask is it larger or smaller than the
thing I'm looking for and based on that
I'm either going to search the front
half or the back half of the list ooh
that's nice okay because if you think
about it in something that was just a
linear algorithm that each step are
reduced the size of the problem by one I
went from a problem of size n to a
problem of size n minus 1 to a problem
of size n minus 2 here I'm taking a
problem of size n I'm reducing it to n
over 2 in one step because I can throw
half the list away so this is a version
of divide and conquer things we've seen
before I'm breaking it down into smaller
versions of the problem so let's look at
that and then we'll let's write some
code and then let's analyze it so
suppose I have a list of size n right
there n elements in there I'm going to
look at the middle one say is it the
thing I'm looking for if it's not is it
bigger than or less than the thing I'm
looking for and in this case let's
assume that in fact the thing I'm
looking for is smaller than that element
great I'm going to throw away half the
list now I only have to look at the
lower half of the list I'll do the same
thing a look at the element in the
middle here and I'll say is it the thing
I'm looking for if not is it bigger than
or smaller than the thing I'm looking
for getting them down to n over two
elements after I do that I throw away
half the list again in this case I'm
assuming that the thing I'm looking for
is bigger than that middle point until I
find that at each step I'm looking at
the middle element and I'm either
throwing away the left half or the right
half of that list so after I steps
I'm down to a list of size and over 2 to
the eye now what's the worst case the
worst case is the elements not in the
list I'm going to have to keep doing
this until I get down to just a list of
1 element and at that point if I it's
not the thing I'm looking for I know I'm
done and I can stop different pattern
notice how I'm cutting down the size of
the problem by two so I can ask before
we look at the code what's the
complexity of this how many steps do I
have to go through in the worst case and
I know I'm going to be done looking at
the list when n over 2 to the I is equal
to 1 meaning there's only one element
left that I'm still looking at and I can
solve that it says I'm going to have to
take up most I equal to log n steps
all right so logarithmic Li I'm cutting
this down and so there we complexity of
the recursion we haven't talked about
the code yet but in terms of the number
of steps I have to do in the worst case
is just logarithmic in the length of the
list that's nice a lot better than
looking at everything inside the list
and in fact you can see it right I don't
look at everything inside the list here
I'm throwing half of the things away at
a time ok so let's look at some code to
do that bisection search I'm going to
give it a list of numbers I'm going to
give it something I'm looking for we can
walk through this code hopefully it's
something you're going to be able to
recognize pretty clearly says if the
list is empty there's nothing there
thing I'm looking for can't be there I
return false if there's exactly one
element in the list then I just check it
if that thinks the thing I'm looking for
returned true otherwise return false I'm
just going to return the value there
otherwise find the midpoint notice the
integer division here find the midpoint
in that list and check it in particular
say if the thing at the midpoint is
bigger than the thing I'm looking for
then I'm going to return a recursive
call to this function only looking at
the first half of the list I'm just
slicing into it otherwise I'll do the
same thing on the second half of the
list
nice this is implementing exactly what I
said we could actually try it I'll do
that in a second if I remember but let's
think about complexity here that's
constant alright doesn't depend on the
size of the list that's constant doesn't
depend on the size of the list that's
constant sounds good and what about that
well it looks like it should be constant
right other than the number of times I
have to go through here remember I know
I'm going to have order log in recursive
calls I'm looking at what's the cost to
set it up it looks like it should be
constant so does that but I'm going to
claim it's not anybody see why it's not
you can look at the slides you've
already printed out right there I'm
actually copying the list right when I
slice into the list like that it makes a
copy of the list Oh crud supposed to say
something different but I won't because
this is going to cost me a little bit as
I think about the work so let's look at
that a little more carefully
I've got order log in search calls we
just deduced that I've just repeated it
here right on each call I'm reducing the
size of the list in half so it goes from
n to n over 2 to n over 4 to n over 8
and over 16 I'll be done in the worst
case when I get down to having only a
list of size one that takes log n steps
because n over 2 to the log n sent over
N which is 1 but to set up the search
for each cell I've got to copy the list
and the list starts out and long so in
principle I've got order and work to do
to set up the recursive call and so by
the things we saw last time I've got
order log in for the number of recursive
calls times order and work inside of
each call and that's order n log n so
it's not what I wanted
now if you're thinking about this
carefully you'll realize on each step
I'm not actually copying the whole list
I'm copying half the list and then 1/4
of the list and then 1/8 of the list so
if I was actually really careful I'm not
going
do the math here in fact what we'll see
and if you like you in your copious
spare time you can go off and work this
through what you'll discover is that
you're actually doing order and work to
do the copying but that's still the
problem because then I got something
that's order n plus log in and the N is
going to dominate so this is still
linear sounds like I led you down a
primrose path here can we fix this sure
because we could do the following we
could say when I want to look at that
list do I need to copy everything what
about if instead I said here's the
beginning and the end of the list when I
test the middle I'll move one of the
pointers to the middle of the list when
I test the middle again I'll move
another pointer in so in other words I
can test the middle and based on that I
could say I only need to search this
part of the list just keep track of that
point and that point in the list and
when I test the middle again same idea
now I'm not actually copying the list
I am simply keeping track of where the
pieces of the list that bound my search
ha all right I'm still reducing the size
of the problem by a factor of two at
each step that's great all I need to do
now though is just keep track of which
portion of the list I'm searching I'm
going to avoid copying the list so the
number of recursive calls a game will be
logarithmic let's see if that actually
fixes my problem a little bit of code
not as bad as it looks I've got an
internal function here then I'm going to
come back to but let's look at what
happens in this case I'm going to say
game if there's nothing in the list just
return false element can't possibly be
there otherwise call this function with
the list the element for whom I'm
searching in the beginning and end of
the list so zero at one inch length
around L minus one at the other and it's
just that idea of I'm keeping track of
the two pieces okay now let's look at
what this does says here's the low part
of the list the high part of the list
initially it's zero and length of list
minus one it says if they are the same
cool then I've got a list of length one
just test to see if it's the thing I'm
looking for if they're not find the
midpoint and the midpoints just the
average of lo plus high integer division
by to think about if it's zero and n
midpoint is in over two but if it's for
example n over 2 and n midpoint is 3/4
in so that mid picks the middle point if
it's the thing I'm looking for great I'm
done otherwise check to see is the thing
at the middle bigger than or less than
the thing I'm looking for and based on
that I'm going to skip this one for a
second I'm either going to search
everything from the low point up to the
middle point or from the middle point up
to the high point and the last piece
here is if in fact the low point in the
middle point are the same I got a list
of size 1 there's nothing left to do I'm
done okay
I know it's a lot of code it would
invite you just to walk through it but I
want to take you back again to simply
this point and say here's what we're
doing we're starting off with pointers
at the beginning and end of the list
we're testing the middle point on based
on that we're giving a call we're now
the pointer is to the beginning in the
middle of the list simply passing it
down and same as I go through all of
these pieces so that code now gives me
what I'd like because here in the
previous case I had a cost the cost was
to copy the list in this case it's
constant because what am i doing I'm
passing in 3 values and what does it
take to compute those values is a
constant amount of work because I'm
simply computing mid right there just
with an arithmetic operation and that
means order log n steps because they
keep reducing the problem in half and
the cost at each point is constant and
this is as a consequence a really nice
example of a logarithmic complexity
function now if you think about it I'm
cheating slightly second time today
because we said we really
don't care about the implementation we
want to get a sense of the complexity
the algorithm and that's generally true
but here is a place in which the
implementation actually has an impact on
that complexity and I want to be
conscious of that as I make these
decisions but again logarithmic in terms
of number of steps constant work for
each step because I'm just passing in
values and as a consequence the over
algorithm is log notice one other thing
I said I want you to see characteristics
of algorithms that tell you something
about the complexity of that algorithm
something that's iterative and reduces
the problem by size 1 each time from n
to n minus 1 to n minus 2 linear
something that reduces the size of the
problem in half or in thirds or in
quarters each time logarithmic generally
unless I've got a hidden cost somewhere
here's another little example just to
give you a sense of log I want to
convert an integer to a string I know I
can just call STR on it but how might we
do that inside of the machine well
here's a nice little algorithm for it
I'm going to set up something I call
digits it's just a string of all the
digits if the thing I'm trying to
convert is 0 I just return the string 0
otherwise let's run through a little
loop where I take that integer divided
by 10 the remainder of that what is that
oh that's the zeroth or the 1 order of
the first order bit and I'm going to
index into digits to find that and I'm
going to add it on to a string that I'm
dealing and it'll divide I by 10 so this
has given an integer I want to convert
it to a string I divide the integer by
10 take the remainder that gives me the
zeroth or the if you like the ones
element I index into the string and I
record it and then I add it to what I
get by dividing I by 10 and doing the
same thing so I'll just walk down each
of the digits converting it into a
string what I care about is the order
growth here this is all constant all
to worry about here is how many times do
I go through the loop and inside of the
loop this is just constant it doesn't
depend on the size of the integer so how
many times do I go through the loop well
how many times can I divide I by 10 and
that's log of I right so it's not I
itself it's not the size of the integer
it's the number of digits in the integer
and here's another nice example of log
I'll point you again right here and
reduce think the size of the problem by
constant factor in this case by 10 each
time nice characteristic of a
logarithmic algorithm okay we've got
constant we've got log about linear we
saw it last time right something like
searching a list in sequence was an
example of something that was linear in
fact most of the examples we saw last
time were things with iterative loops so
for example fact written it iteratively
factorial write n times n minus 1 times
n minus 2 all the way down to 1 I set
product to 1 I go for a loop where I
goes from 1 update n minus 1 or just
below n minus 1 incrementally
multiplying product by I and restoring
that back away again we know that this
loop here how many times do I go through
it go through it n times the cost inside
the loop there are three steps changing
I am multiplying product times I am
storing that value back and product and
as we saw that constant doesn't matter
this is linear so n times around the
loop constant costs each time order n
what about recursive I could write fact
recursively I actually prefer it this
way right fans less than or equal to 1
return 1 otherwise multiply and by
whatever I get by calling this on n
minus 1 the cost inside the loop is just
constant I'm doing one subtraction one a
multiplication how many times do I go
through it again n times because I got
to go from n to n minus 1 to n minus 2
so again this is linear
now if you were to time it you'd
probably see a difference
my guess is I'm sure professor good
tackle correct me if I get it wrong is
that the factorial one probably takes a
little more time because you've got to
set up the frame for the recursive call
but in terms of what we care about
they're the same they're both linear
they're order N and so interestingly
both iterative or recursive factorial
have same order of growth gain I want
you to notice what's the key here
reducing the size of the problem by 1 is
indicative generally of something that's
going to have linear growth I say in
general if it's a loop inside of a loop
as we saw it might be a little bigger
but this is generally linear constant
log linear log linear that is n log n
we're going to see this next time I'm
simply going to push it ahead which
invites you to come back on Wednesday
and see this it's actually something
that's a really powerful algorithm it's
going to be really useful we're going to
look at something called merge sort
which is a very common sorting algorithm
and has that property being log linear
so we'll come back to this next time
about polynomial well we saw this last
time as well this commonly occurs when
we have nested loops or where we have
nested recursive function calls nested
loop meaning I'm looping over some
variable and inside of there I got
another loop and what we saw is the
outer loop if it's a standard lid
iterative thing will be linear but
inside of the loop I'm doing a linear
amount of work each time so it becomes n
times n so order N squared ok
exponential these are things sorry yes I
did that right I'm going to go back to
the exponential these are things that
we'd like to stay away from but
sometimes we can and the common
characteristic here is when we brought a
recursive function where there's more
than one recursive call inside the
problem
remember towers of Hanoi that wonderful
demonstration I did I was tempted to
bring it back because it's always fun to
get a little bit of applause when I do
it but I won't do it this time but I
remember we
look at that problem-solving the towers
of Hanoi how do I move a stack of size n
of different sized disks from one peg to
another where I can only move the top
disk onto another one I can't cover up a
smaller disk I want to remind you we saw
there was a wonderful recursive solution
to that it said move a stack of size n
minus 1 under the spare peg move the
bottom one and then move that stack over
onto the thing you were headed towards
okay what's the complexity of them while
I'm going to show you a trick for
figuring that out it's called a
recurrence relation for a very
deliberate reason but it'll give us a
little handy way to think about what's
the order of growth here so I'm going to
let T sub n denote the time it takes to
move a tower of size n and I want to get
an expression for how much time is that
going to take what do I know I know
that's 2 times T to the N minus 1 right
I got to move a stack of size 1 less
onto the spare peg and then one to move
that bottom thing over and then whatever
it takes me to move a stack of size n
minus 1 over to that peg okay so how
does that help me
well let's play the same game what's T
of n minus 1 oh that's 2 T of n minus 2
plus 1 just substituting and I'm using
exactly the same relationship here all
right let's just do a little math on
that that's 4 T to the n minus 2 plus 2
plus 1 and you're still going ok who
cares well let's do the same thing one
more time T of n minus 2 that's 2 T of M
minus 3 plus 1 Oh see the pattern you
can start to see you two merge here
right each time I reduce this I'm adding
another power of 2 and I'm increasing
the coefficient up front and so in fact
after K steps I'll have 1 plus 2 plus 4
all the way up to 2 to the K minus 1
plus 2 to the K times T sub n minus K
hopefully you can see it if you just
look at this expression is
all of those up there I'm just pulling
it out each time when am i done when
this is size zero when K is equal to M
and so that's when I get that expression
if this is going by too fast just walk
it through yourself later on but I'm
literally just using this expression to
do the reduction until I see the pattern
all right what's that well if you're a
course 18 major you've seen it before if
you haven't here's a nice little trick
let me let a equal that sum 2 to the N
minus 1 plus 2 to the n minus 2 all the
way down to 1 let me multiply both the
left and the right side by 2 that gives
me 2 a is equal to 2 to the n plus 2 to
the n minus 1 all the way down to 2 I'm
just taking each of the terms
multiplying them by 2 now subtract this
from that and on the left side you get a
and on the right side you get that term
these all cancel out minus 1 geometric
series cool
so that sum is just 2 to the n minus 1
and if I plug that back in there ah I've
got my order growth exponential 2 to the
N okay I was a math physics undergrad
I'd like these kinds of things but I
wanted you to see how we can reason
through it because this is letting us
see the growth what I want you to pull
away from this is notice the
characteristic and towers of Hanoi want
to do another example in a second the
characteristic was at the recursive step
I had not one but two recursive calls
and that is characteristic of something
with exponential growth which I just saw
here two to the N that by the way I
remind you the story of towers have on
our towers of Hanoi right when the
priests in that temple moved the entire
stack from one peg to another we all
reached Nirvana and the world ends n is
equal to 64 here go figure out what 2 to
the 64 is and if you're doing one move
per second which they will I think we're
certainly going to be here awhile before
the universe ends and we reached Nirvana
probably
several times over we are new vonner
word MIT you're right John but we're
worrying about the rest of the world so
okay we'll keep moving on Nirvana will
be next week when they do the quiz John
so we'll keep moving quickly all right I
want to show you one more example it's a
cool problem for math but mostly to see
that characteristic of exponential
growth and then we're going to pull all
of this together this is something
called the power set so if I have a set
of things well let's assume I have a set
of integers with no repeats so 1 through
n 1 2 3 4 for example I want to generate
the collection of all possible subsets
so subsets with no elements with one
element with two elements with three
months all the way up to n elements so
for example if my set is 1 through 4
then the power set would be the empty
set with no elements in it all of the
instances with 1 element all of them
with 2 all over 3 and all of them with 4
I'd like to write code to generate this
it's actually a handy problem in number
theory or in set theory by the way the
order doesn't matter I could do it this
way but this would be a perfectly
reasonable way of generating it as well
and I'm going to come back to that in a
second as we think about solving this
the question is how would I go about
finding all of these I'm going to use
well could stop and say you can imagine
writing a big iterative loop you start
with N and you decide do I include it or
not and then you still go to n minus 1
do I include it or not you could think
about writing a big loop that would
generate all of these actually a bunch
of nested loops but there's a nice
recursive solution and I want you
encourage you to think that ways so
here's the way I'm going to do it what
do we do when we said we want to think
recursively we say let's assume we can
solve a smaller size problem if I want
to generate the power set of all the
integers from one day and I'm going to
assume that I can generate the power set
of integers from 1 to n minus 1 if I
have that solution then I can construct
the solution to the bigger problem
really easily Wow well all of the things
that were in
that solution to the smaller problem
have to be part of the solution to the
bigger problem there are all subsets of
1 to n because they're all subsets of 1
to n minus 1 so I'm going to add all
those in and then I'm going to say let's
take each one of those and add em to
each of those subsets because that gives
me all the rest of the solutions I've
got all the ways to find solutions
without n I get all the ways to find
solutions with him that may sound like a
lot of gobbledygook let me show you the
example there is the power set of the
empty set it's just the empty set to get
the power set of 1 I include that and I
include a version of everything there
with 1 added to it
there's the power set of 1 now given
that how do I get the power set of 2
well both of those are certainly things
I want and for each one of them let me
just add 2 if you look at that right
that's the set of all ways of getting
nothing one two or both of them and you
get the idea now having that solution I
can get the solution for three because
all of those have to belong and I simply
add 3 to each one of those oh that's
cool right all right you don't have to
be a math geek to admit it's cool it is
kind of cool because it says G got a
solution to the salt smaller problem
generating the next piece is a natural
step you can also see the size of that
sets doubling each time because to get
to 4 I'm going to add everything into
all of those pieces really nice
recursive description let's write some
code so I'll hand that out to you but
here's the code and I'm going to walk
through it carefully and then we're
going to analyze it but it's actually
for me a beautiful piece of code I did
not write it by the way John did but
it's a beautiful piece of code I want to
generate all the subsets or the power
set of some list of elements here's how
I'm going to do it I'm going to set up
some internal variable called res ok and
then what am I going to do
actually I don't know why put residen
there I don't need it but we'll come
back
- that if the list is empty length of
the list is zero I'm going to just
return that solution and this is not a
typo what is that funky thing there it
is a list of one element which is the
empty list which I need because the
solution in this case is a set with
nothing in it so there is the thing I
returned in the base case otherwise what
do I do I take all the elements of the
list except the last one and I call it
recursively I generate all of the
subsets of that perfect I'm going to
call that smaller I then take the last
element and I make a list of just the
last element and what did I say I need
to do I need all of these guys plus I
need all of them where I add that
element in oh nice I'll set up new as a
variable here and I'll loop over all of
the elements from the smaller problem
where I basically add that list to that
list and I put it into new that's simply
taking all of the solutions of subsets
of up to M minus 1 and creating a new
set of subsets where N is included in
every one of them and now I take this
and I take that I penned them or
concatenate them rather shouldn't say
append them concatenate them together
and return it that's a crisp piece of
code and I'm sorry John I have no idea
where I put res up there I don't think I
need that anywhere in this code and I
won't blame it on John it was my recopy
of the code sorry maybe right look I
know I'm flaming at you I get to do it
I'm tenured as I've said multiple times
in this course that's a cool piece of
code imagine trying to write it with a
bunch of loops iterating over indices
good luck you can do it maybe be on the
quiz actually note one that's way too
hard to ask but it's a cool piece of
code because I can look at it and say
what's the solution solve the smaller
problem and then given that take every
one of the things in that smaller
problem add that
element into that and put the two pieces
together wonderful okay with that in
mind let's see if we can figure out the
complexity of this up here that's
constant that's okay right there I've
got the recursive call so I know first
of all that this is going to call itself
n times right because each stage reduces
the size of the problem by one so if I'm
trying to get the power set of n I'm
going to have to do it to get n minus 1
and then n minus 2 so I know the
recursion of GN subsets to Gen subsets
this is going to go around n times
that's not so bad but right down here
I've got to figure out what's the cost
of this right this is constant that's
setting up is constant that's constant
but there I've got another loop and the
loop depends on how big smaller is and
smaller is a bad choice of term here
because it's going to grow on me but
let's think about it by the way I'm
assuming a pendous constant time which
generally it is the time I need to solve
this problem includes the time to solve
the smaller problem that recursive call
I know that's going to be linear but I
also need the time it takes to make the
copy of all the things in that smaller
version so how big is that Oh crud
number two number of things in the
powerset grows as a factor of two right
if I got something you know one through
three I've got all the things with
nothing in it all the things with one is
it all the things with two things in it
all the things with three things in it
that's eight and each time around I'm
doubling the size of it so for a set of
size K there are 2 to the K cases and
that says that this loop right here is
going to be growing exponentially
because I got to go down that entire
list to find all of the pieces so what's
the overall complexity I'm going to play
the same game let's let T sub n capture
the time it takes to solve a problem of
size n
just temporarily I'm going to let S sub
n denote the size of the solution for a
problem of size n how big is that things
smaller and what do I know
the amount of time it takes me to solve
the problem of size n it's the amount of
time it takes me to solve the slightly
smaller problem that's the recursive
call to Gen sub sets plus the amount of
time it takes me to run over that loop
looking at everything and smaller and
adding in a new version plus some
constant C which is just the number of
constant operations the constant steps
inside that loop okay and if I go back
to it T sub n is cost here T sub n minus
1 is the cost there a sub n is the size
of this and then I got one two three
four five constant steps so C is
probably five in this case so what can I
say there's the relationship because I
know s then minus one is two to the N
minus one there are two to the n minus
one elements inside of that how do I
deal with this let's play the same game
what's T sub n minus one that's T of n
minus two plus two to the N minus two
plus C and I could keep doing this you
can see what the pattern is going to
look like I'm going to have K times C
constant steps for each reduction I'm
going to get another power of two and
I'm going to reduce this overall term
after K steps to T to the N minus K when
am I done when that's down to something
of size zero and there's the expression
and what you can see is what I wanted
you to see order in our sorry order two
to the N is exponential in the size of
the problem what's the characteristic
something that has a recursive call so I
multiple recursive calls that each step
is likely to lead to exponential but
that can also be buried inside of how I
grow the size of the problem and that
was the case here there's only one
recursive call
but that loop grows in size each time
around so the complexity is exponential
I'm going to pull this together I said
one of the things I'd like you to start
to recognize is what are the
characteristics of a choice and
algorithm that leads to a particular
complexity class and you now have some
of them the code doesn't depend on the
size of the problem that's constant and
in fact we've been using that as we look
at pieces of the code if we can reduce
the problem set in this case by half
each time by some constant factor from n
to n over 2 to n over 4 to n over 8 that
tends to be characteristic unless
there's a hidden cost somewhere else
of a logarithmic algorithm these are
really nice simple things that reduce
the size of the problem by one at each
step an iterative call that goes from n
to n minus 1 and then to n minus 2 and
then to n minus 3 characteristic of
linear algorithms log linear we're going
to see next time polynomial typically
quadratic and squared when we have
nested loops or nested recursive calls
looping over something inside of there
and looping over something else on a
size that depends on the size of the
problem and then we just saw this last
when multiple recursive calls at each
level tends to be characteristic of
exponential and as I said we'd like to
be as high up in this list as we can
because those are really nice algorithms
to have let me give you one more example
I'm looking at this and then we'll be
done fibonacci standard problem right
the nth Fibonacci number is the sum of
the previous two Fibonacci numbers this
was the example we saw of multiplying
rabbits if you like here's an iterative
version of Fibonacci just as if n is
zero it's just zero if it's 1 it's just
1 otherwise I'm going to set up
initially the two previous Fibonacci
numbers and then I'm just going to run
through a loop where I temporarily keep
track of that number I move the second
previous one into the last previous one
I add those two that becomes the second
previous number and I just keep running
through that loop you can go run it you
see it does the right thing what I want
to look at is the complexity so that's
constant
constant that's linear because the work
inside the loop is constant but I'm
doing it n times so this is nice water
so I should say the bottom thing is
constant the overall algorithm the worst
case is just order n great what about
the recursive version for me this is
much nicer code it's nice and clean it
says of n is equal to zero fib of 0 0 if
that is equal to 1 fib of 1 or the first
and second Fibonacci numbers of 0 1
otherwise just return what I get by
summing both of those pieces and you can
probably already guess what the
complexity is going to be here right
because I've now got two recursive calls
inside of this call so one way to think
about it is if I'm going to solve the
problem up here I've got to solve two
versions of the problem below which has
got to solve two versions of the problem
below and in general this is going to be
exponential 2 to the n now you say wait
a minute I was paying attention with
this guy was yeah Turing on a couple of
weeks ago honest I was and in fact what
we saw was that fib isn't balanced in
terms of how it goes right it's not that
on the right-hand side of the tree I
have to solve all of those portions
because the problem gets smaller does
that change the complexity well the
answer is it changes the base but it's
actually still exponential and if you
want to go look this up I'm sure you can
find you know Wikipedia very quickly
this actually has a very cool
exponential growth it's the golden ratio
to the nth power and in fact I encourage
you to go look at it and even more
copious spare time you have it's a very
cool proof to see it but the bottom line
is while we can do a little bit better
than 2 to the N it still grows
exponentially within so what do we have
we got Big O notation as a way of
talking about comparing efficiency of
algorithms what I want you to see here
is that you ought to be able to
begin to reason about what's the cost of
an algorithm by recognizing those common
patterns I keep saying it but it's going
to be really valuable to you and you
should be able to therefore work the
other direction when you're given a new
problem how do I get this into a linear
algorithm if I can log linear if I can
we'd be really great but if you know I
can't how do I stay away from
exponential algorithms and finally what
we're going to show later on is that in
fact there are some problems that as far
as we know are fundamentally exponential
and they're expensive to compute the
very last thing is you might have
decided I was cheating in a different
way so I'm using a set of built-in
Python functions I'm not going to go
through all of these but this is just a
list for example for lists of what the
complexity of those built-in functions
are and if you look through the list
they kind of make sense you know
indexing you can go straight to that
point computing the length you compute
it once you've stored it comparison
order n because I got to compare all the
elements of the list similarly to remove
something from the list I got to find
where it is in the list and remove it
worst case that's going to be order in
so you can see that these operations are
typically linear in the size of this
these are constant for dictionaries
remember dictionaries were this nice
thing they weren't ordered it gave me a
power in terms of storing them but as a
consequence some of the costs then go up
for a list indexing going to a
particular point I just go to that spot
and retrieve it indexing into a
dictionary I have to find that point in
the dictionary that has the key and get
the value back so that's going to be
linear because I have to in principle
walk all the way down it it's a slight
misstatement as we'll see later on a
dictionary actually uses a clever
indexing scheme called a hash but in the
worst case this is going to be linear so
you see a trade-off for dictionaries I
get more power I get more flexibility
but it comes as a cost and so these
basically are what let me reason on top
of the things I've been doing to figure
out complexity and next time we'll do
the last piece of this when we look at
sorting so we'll see you on Wednesday